[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to do this episode we're covering
DC's latest comic book extravaganza
Shazam and breaking down everything that
you need to know about the movies ending
and all the cool early stir eggs that
are in the film make sure you stick
around until the end for my review of
Shazam where I'll be letting you know
whether to go out and see in theaters or
just to wait for the blu-ray from here
on out its full spoilers ahead so if you
don't want to know anything about the
film then I highly recommend that you
turn off now for everyone else thanks
for clicking the video sit back relax
and let's get into my ending explain
breakdown of Shazam Shazam opens with a
young dr. sivana traveling home with his
brother and father
Suvarna is really looked down upon by
the two and we get the feeling that his
brother is the favorite while see sort
of the outcast things start looking up
though when he's transported to the rock
of eternity during a ride and he meets a
wizard known as Shazam Shazam is in
search for someone pure of heart to
tackle the manifestations of the seven
deadly sins but when they eventually
break out of their holdings in his
dimension there's a little cameo from
mr. mind which I'll get into more later
and it seems like Suvarna is going to be
the next champion until the whisperings
of the sins tempt him to take their
power due to this Suvarna is cast out
and back on the road he accidentally
causes his father to crash the car
they're riding in paralyzing him in the
process eagle-eyed DC fans will
recognize sivanna's father as actor John
Glover who also played Lionel Luthor in
TV Smallville man that guy is amazing at
raising super villains anyway
flash-forward to current day and we
joined Billy Batson fourteen-year-old
boy who's in search of his mother Batson
luster during a visit to the carnival
and it's been moving from foster home to
foster home trying to track it down to
no avail there's a nice little reference
to Batman Begins and The Dark Knight
Rises with the policeman putting a
blanket around the
Batson in order to comfort him after
just losing his parents it's just a
shame that Commissioner Gordon wasn't on
the case because maybe he could have
found his mother as the excuse they gave
that he couldn't track her down is that
she just changed her maiden name which
hmm
anyway Batson gets moved to a new foster
home and quickly forms a friendship with
the other children there including
superhero obsessed Freddie Freeman
Freddie owns a replica batarangs has
multiple aquaman t-shirts and even
managed to obtain a deflected bullet
that was shot off Superman meanwhile a
dr. sivana has spent decades looking for
a way back to the rock of eternity so
that he can prove he's worthy after
interviewing multiple people with shared
experiences sivanna figures out the
symbols to create a doorway back to the
realm taking the original power that the
sins tempted him with whilst they
possess and inhabit his body left with
no real choice the wizard Shazam bestows
the power of Shazam upon Billy who with
the help of Freddy slowly starts to
figure out his powers there's some
absolutely hilarious scenes in here when
Billy stopped to store robbery and he
quickly becomes a local celebrity
racking up thousands of views on YouTube
a bit like another hero that I know
don't forget to like subscribe comment
it anyway the fame sort of goes to
Billy's head and it becomes more of an
acting hero dodging his responsibilities
as much as possible and we all know with
great power comes never mind that's
wrong hero because of this he and Freddy
fall out and Freddy sort of becomes a
laughingstock at school after bragging
that Shazam would have lunch with him as
he's his best friend but guess what he
never shows sivanna aware that if Billy
gains his full potential he'll be able
to defeat him tracks him down and tries
to take his power there's an awesome
floor keyboard reference too big which
is of course a big influence on this
film but Billy takes the coward's way
out during the fight and the police from
it sivanna spots Freddy who recognizes
from a new shot and kidnaps him which
leads him to the foster home where he
holds the family hostage at this point
with the help of his foster brother and
some Hackerman skills Billy tracks down
his mother but upon showing up at her
door he realizes that she purposely
toom at the carnival when she realized
that she wouldn't be able to take care
of him properly due to her only being 17
and his father being in jail shout-outs
Barry Allen anyway Billy realizes he has
a new family and returns at the home to
take Sivan Head on who takes him to the
rock of eternity to transfer his powers
the foster family follow him and after
Freddy throws up bat-arang off his head
they realized that he goes back to being
mortal if the sins were out of him
cue some Monsters Inc inspired doorways
and a cameo from crocodile man and
eventually the group returned to the
carnival that belly was left at which is
where sivanna shows up to take his power
once more
Shazam realizing that his power comes
from the heart and that his family are
that to him now is able to transfer his
power into all of his foster family and
thus create the Shazam kids anyone who's
read flashpoint knows how badass these
guys are and I love that Adam Brody
finally got to be in a DC film for those
who don't know Brody was actually cast
as the flash George Miller's Justice
League film however the movie was
cancelled just days before it was due to
shoot so it finally seems like justice
is served
sorry that joke was terrible anyway they
defeat the sins and Billy is able to
deep power sivanna and lock him up their
fight his Man of Steel written all over
it with some hilarious villain
monologuing that falls on deaf ears
the family grow closer and Freddy sits
down for lunch which is when Shazam
joins him confirming that they do indeed
know each other just to add some extra
umph to the end of the film
Shazam says he brought a friend which is
when Superman walks in and sits down
beside them now this last shot can be
taken two ways we never actually see
Henry Cavill in the suit and Superman's
appearance is completely neck down I did
actually have a member of staff from
Warner Brothers contact me a couple of
months back after they got to see an
assembly curve the film and they said
that the Superman shot was originally
supposed to be an insert whilst they
work things out behind the scenes with
Henry Cavill unfortunately it doesn't
look like they were able to come to an
agreement but I actually think the shot
still works and that Warner Brothers
probably managed to save a shedload of
money cut the credits and we get an
awesome animation that shows Shazam
interacting with the rest of the Justice
League and kind of owning them laughs
right
now the first post credit scene picks up
with dr. sivana in his cell trying to
recreate the symbols to open the door
back to the rock of eternity I'll know
where a raspy robotic voice tells him
that it's useless and there are other
ways to obtain magic which is when we
see mr. mind who escaped the rock of
eternity earlier has returned mind is
part of the monster Society of evil and
this is a sort of lower tier Legion of
Doom made up of members like gummy mr.
hoo and crocodile man black Adam has to
been a member from time to time and this
sets up the casting of the rock as the
character for the inevitable sequel
because let's face it this movie's gonna
kill it
sivanna eventually joins them and this
meeting makes a lot of sense for the
future personally though I've always
viewed these as kind of joke characters
and they're not really headline acts for
DC graphic novels so it seems strange
that Warner Brothers have decided that
they should be the next foe but
obviously they bring a wealth of
dynamics to the proceedings so it seems
like creators are aiming to continue the
fun and friendly aesthetic of this movie
the last post-credit scene is just a gag
that was shown in trailers and doesn't
really tease anything for the future the
scene shows Shazam attempting to speak
to his fish as Freddie Freeman watches
this is of course a little nudge and
acknowledgement of Aquaman but it's
bound to disappoint those who are
expecting a big cameo from one of DCs
a-listers and now on to my review Shazam
was a hell of a lot of fun DC have been
criticized recently of copying Marvel
too much but here the family friendly
vibe works a treat the movie is
hilarious from start to finish
and there's a self-awareness to it that
makes it really easy to get into casting
is pitch perfect here with Jack Dillon
who plays Freddy Freeman
really being the runaway star for me he
adds a wealth of humor to the
performance but also hot when necessary
Zachary Levi Zachary Levi Zachary Levi
is about to become a household name and
I promise in a couple of months I'll be
able to pronounce his name properly
because he feels like he embodies a kid
that's been bestowed with these powers
well so do you think the third act goes
on a bit too long with a ferris wheel
scene that was completely unnecessary
ultimately this is another step forward
for DC who've been nailing
this is the best Captain Marvel movie of
the year and you should definitely go
and check this out in theaters as it's
gonna be a big boy
okay and lastly how would i rank the
entire DC you lineup from best to worst
now I'm not going to include the Dark
Knight trilogy in this list as it's
unfair on the rest of the films and this
is strictly from Man of Steel onwards so
my ranking after seeing Shazam would go
Man of Steel at number one I know this
is a controversial pick but I think the
film perfectly showcases what our world
would be like if a superhero entered in
and that fight at the end whilst a
little long-winded set the stage for a
lot of superhero movies going forward
next is Shazam again a brilliant
superhero movie that feels quite
grounded in scenarios that I and I'm
guessing a lot of teenagers will be able
to relate to after that is the extended
cut and a half distress extended cut of
Batman V Superman while so do you think
this will probably rub people the wrong
way being so high up on the list I do
really enjoy the film and it has the
best Batman fight scene ever put to a
movie next up is Wonder Woman which is a
brilliant movie that knocked it out the
park for the most part I just feel like
it suffers from the origin story
problems that most first outings do and
its last act is where the movie falls
apart then it would be Aquaman whilst I
really enjoyed the movie that pitbull
song made me die a little inside then
it's Justice League that movie is just a
mess to me and cavils mustache ruins the
entire thing I'll never forgive you Tom
Cruise and last but not least well it is
least is Academy Award winner Suicide
Squad look you know the movies bad when
the sequel is a reboot
so yeah let's not get into it okay so
that's pretty good for Shazam right it
ranks pretty high and I'm looking
forward to watching it again obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
film and where you rank it amongst the
rest of the DC Universe
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then make sure you
check out my full breakdown of last
week's big movie us which would be
linked at the end I also do a comic book
movie podcast called watching The
Watchmen the hardcore DC fans who want a
bit more long-form analysis of their
favorite boots which are leave a link to
you after this video this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]